so for those that have been living under
a rock because everyone has seen
Yellowstone if they have it what is
Yellowstone about yeah I mean I have a
quick way to sort of describe it it's
sort of like Godfather the family's sort
of like the Godfather there's also some
Greek tragedy you mix that with Big Sky
country and that's kind of the show yeah
oh my God that's actually a really good
way to describe the show cool your
character Jamie is so intense like I
often just find myself like this just
watching your character because it's
just I know you're actors and you you
know perform and then you go home like I
do like at a show or something are you
doing a show but it it just seems like
is that hard not to carry that weight
home because your characters maybe the
hardest I think on the show yeah I can't
compare because I don't know what
they're all going through but I know
it's it's been a trip but I had prided
myself as a viewer I feel sorry for you
yeah well yeah even when you're kind of
a jerk I'm just still sorry for you I
like it I'll take it I need it for the
healing it's tough you know like I used
to pride myself on thing I go before I
went home but this one by season two or
three my wife was like you are different
what's happening yeah and so I was
carrying him home and basically now he
has the floor and Wes is kind of off in
the back waiting for his moment again
dude yeah it's an intense role and even
like you said the golfer even the
dynamic of family in it is really
hardcore very tough it seems with Beth
are tough you know and she it's a it's a
hard thing to get through but we trust
each other it's that's how we do it but
yeah
I'm just like
it's a whole just a whole show in itself
I'm just like there's a lot in there
yeah that character I'm just like what
are these writers doing oh yeah um
anyway it's so good though um so were
either of you comfortable in horses or
were you those actors that totally lied
and said I can ride a horse and couldn't
I think it was on my resume that I could
ride a horse but no but that's totally
wasn't real okay not at all yeah it was
terrible you look like you can ride a
horse I can a little bit now you know
we've been working on it for five years
at this point but you know they've had
us doing a lot of uh you know working
with some really good people doing some
Cowboy camps that sort of thing so yeah
a little better now Wait is is Cowboy
camp like flickers I imagine that's what
that's what
actors like
yeah yeah they were like they were we
went on this Cowboy camp that we had
these like Paul Bunyan type real cowboys
who do pack rides yeah and like we
wanted we were to go out in the Off the
Grid and live with them and try to
survive and learn how to ride horses and
stuff but it was an adventure though
wait that sounds fun it was crazy though
we had we kind of got separated from
those Paul Bunyan types and it was just
actors alone in the Wizard
how do you have this one get separated
they're just playing a prank on you and
they leave you like what we were
wondering if it was like part of the
thing like they're doing this on purp
they'll be here any minute yeah no no we
didn't see them to the next day and
you're in Montana or Utah at that point
yeah oh I was like were there were bears
and more bears there too yeah I'm like
on my property alone all of that exists
we thought we saw a bear in the distance
you remember that we were like there was
some figure way off and we couldn't
figure out what exactly it was I think
it was one of the Cowboys
making sure we didn't die Did you ever
ride horses before or did you I did the
same thing I put it on my resume and
actually I got really close to a job
beloved this movie by Jonathan Demi and
they they they put me on a train out to
Philadelphia from New York to meet him
to get this role small role but it is
important to me and and I went and met
with him and we walked the hallway and
he was sort of like can you do a can you
do an accent like yeah I could do
accents he says can you ride a horse I
said yeah yeah yeah yeah
right yeah
he said once you go over there to the
Wranglers and ride some horses and
they'll see where you're at and I just
panicked and I got on and as soon as I
got on they knew I was
that is frightening that you just
they're like hop on a horse and go yeah
as soon as you touch him they're like
dang they took off yeah they sense fear
don't be fearful
um are your kids into the show oh yeah I
mean they don't watch it
just Beth alone yeah in fact I do know
some dad things that aren't right to do
this one's not watch Yellowstone yet but
um no they uh they wanted to ride horses
at first and they did and then went back
and forth but what my son was really up
to in the first couple seasons was he
was trying to land Luke Grimes attached
to his little script he wrote remember
the character's name uh Microsoft
Luke
[Music]
[Laughter]
he wanted a real isn't it amazing how
humbling it is your kids oh he didn't
care for whatever literally like my kid
said they didn't care at all and
literally I came home and like Ariana
Grande was on the voice of me and they
were like who and I was like what yeah
like they don't care what you do
something so this show 18 23 it's your
first major like acting role because I
know that you're in Stepford Wives and
you've been in some things yeah I love
that one so it was it something that
you've always wanted to do and you like
dipped your toes in a little bit but
then you decided to just jump in yes I
started singing in church yeah but the
first thing that I did when I was in
middle lower school middle school high
school were plays I was on stage all the
time then my career took off no time had
babies kept on having babies felt like I
was having babies all the time yeah and
I had done a couple of things I did
Stepford Wives and with an amazing cast
amazing amazing cast it wasn't the best
experience so I said I will never ever
ever ever
do another
because it took so long the waiting for
me you have to understand hurry up and
wait I cannot I have to be like do busy
doing stuff yeah anyway and then I did
an independent thing called Dixieland
but have you know had I've read a lot of
scripts over the years and nothing never
really hit you nothing hit me or the
timing wasn't right and then for the
script to have been so incredibly well
written I honestly had never read
anything like it we're talking about
1883. yeah and uh
so we just made the decision to
do it to do it Tim and I have been
married 26 years this year
congratulations
that can be hard really not all of us
make it it's okay that's amazing were
you excited about doing it together yeah
or were you a little intimidated by it
well I'm intimidated by him because he's
an amazing actor first of all all of the
actors on the show everyone was so like
top the game
behind the camera in front of the camera
um but I I did have to say I I did have
the rule for me personally because we've
been together for so long and we are
together all the time it's one it's
glorious
[Laughter]
we love it we love it really all of it
togetherness yeah
but it is kind of it is kind of cool
though like the different role like is
it cool to play someone back then
because y'all shot you shot in Texas my
home state but you also I live in
Montana as well and you shot in Montana
as well so wait that's really hot or
really cold which one was harder well
okay I would I from Mississippi so the
humidity the heat I could you're kind of
used to that I could deal with it it was
Texas though it's God's hair different
it is but the cold the wind
um combined with the cold in Montana was
yeah almost too much to bear it is if
you're not dressed properly it it slaps
you no no it really pierces your your
entire everything
um but my rule with Tim I said look if
we're going to do this together this we
cannot run lines together ever we cannot
talk about the scene that's we're
filming tomorrow ever because
you want it to be something else like
separate well I that was in my opinion
the only way for me I I I mean um you
know
for me to bring to make it to feel real
and authentic and I I it had to be when
the cameras were rolling were on set
roll that was the first time I met James
was on that set yeah we were working
together when we were filming although I
know him so well so otherwise I'd have
been like maybe you shouldn't do that
yeah you know what I'm saying judging it
yeah like don't do your face like that
when you say that word and and him to me
this I'm you know yes again being funny
she loves him
um so much I do she loves him I know I
know well Tim in 1883 of Faith plays
your wife so that must have been a
stretch um and Isabel plays your
daughter
um did she fit in right in with your
family I feel like literally I'm looking
at a girl that could have come from
y'all so when we first saw Izzy when we
walked first day of cowboy Camp when we
walked in I mean of course she's she's
just beautiful and sweet and so poised
and so mature uh but when we first saw
her we went right right away we thought
my gosh she she looks like she could be
our daughter I mean it was just perfect
casting and uh and then and the more we
got to know her the sweeter she got and
and the more we grew to love her and and
respected her and and um she she's just
uh she's a she's an incredible she just
shines in this show and and anybody who
knows her and it was around her own set
knows that she stuck shines in person as
well and in real life oh that's so I
miss you too so sweet
what I have to ask like what is first of
all we're going to get back to Cowboy
camp that sounds like City Slickers the
movie and I'm very excited about it
um I love that film all of them um but
what what was it like having Tim and
famous parents in in a show that's crazy
I'm yeah uh kind of incredible I mean
Tim knows this already so this isn't a
big shock to him but I didn't know who
they were
yes I didn't know that they were big
what rock did you live under
I know you're young I guess you're like
21 or yes but my wife like might I just
I don't know I hide away oh my God
you're so lucky though you have all this
music to catch up on I know and I'm very
excited but to me I I just got to get to
know them as just human they're just you
know yeah there was a blank slate and my
goodness are they just the loveliest
people I think I've ever met I've
immediately fell in love with them and
it was so genuine and and I mean Faith
Hill is one of the kindest people I
think I've ever met in my life and she's
a goofball and she's funny she's a
goofball oh my goodness she makes animal
noises weird animal noises wait what
yeah she's so gifted at it too okay I'll
stop there
next time I have faith on that will be
when I ask her give me an animal noise
um yeah oh I did a little bit of it
I don't know if that was gonna work I
love it I love it um so Zachary is an
actor who acts but also sings but you
are a singer who acts you're in
Yellowstone I didn't know that and she's
great in Yellowstone
thank you very much I just found this
out so if you always wanted to act is
this also an Avenue that you've always
wanted to do you know what songwriting
has always been my number one yeah no
matter what I mean
just keep talking it sounds like I got a
bunch of whiskey soap marbles in my
mouth but
um but I've always I've Loved country
music I mean where I'm from Northeast
Louisiana yeah it's a town of 200 people
little town called Baskin and we eat
sleep and breathe country music so that
was my my focus but when this
opportunity came up yeah I mean I was
like this is going to be a way for me to
share my music with the world you dang
ride them will take it listen yeah it's
an incredibly cool show and then it's
also just a like you never know it's
it's important that you say yes to
things that maybe you know like you were
like well I didn't think that but look
at this I know stepping outside of that
comfort zone doing things that are scary
but Yellowstone so y'all shot in Montana
I have a Rancher it's beautiful do you
just love it it's beautiful yeah and I
live in Brooklyn so I'm so different
yeah I'm ready to get the hell out yeah
I gotta go back to Montana I know I'm
just such a different experience so when
you go there is it just like do you feel
like you've gone back in time it's like
it's such a different thing than a city
a major city totally and it's it's such
a nice Community where we shoot and I'm
so glad that we don't you know we don't
shoot in a Sound Stage we shoot on this
beautiful Ranch yeah and um yeah I mean
it looks like a backdrop honestly it
feels like it's probably easier to get
into character and do all that stuff too
when it's like real definitely you're
like there yeah it's very immersive yeah
it's such a great show so there's a
whole like Romeo and Juliet thing going
on with care I love that scene it's so
intense oh my God I know we've got to
bring the mood up the attention no I
like it
um so wait so there's this whole Romeo
and Juliet thing because the families
they don't like each other right there's
so many things happening so do you feel
like that with y'all's character that
you're always kind of like you love each
other but you hate each other yeah well
it's um we yeah we started kind of Romeo
and Juliet and now we're really in a
like a survival movie yeah just with
everything that's going on in that World
um they get stuck because y'all move
into the house and at first yeah yeah
yeah and then In that clip I think you
know she's finally confronting Casey
just saying like look I I can't survive
here yeah
um so he's intense old dad he's intense
yeah no it's it's not easy being married
to a Dun yeah I love it okay so what
your character knows her around a horse
so you're from South Carolina but did
you ever ride horses no okay so I was
like did you were you one of those
actors please tell me you're one of
those actors like they're like can you
ride a horse totally oh yeah but never
rode one oh yeah I had a whole paragraph
everything actors
Hunter
jumper I've done it all so wait did you
freak out then when you had to start
riding a horse I mean it's movie magic
thank God for our editor um but and and
are amazing I have an amazing stunt
double but um no I I mean we have the
best horse Wranglers and trainers around
so I'm I'm terrible at riding a horse
but you know it's an it's a nice thing
to go do on your day off yeah oh it's
beautiful there's such Majestic animals
so yeah so your skills in real life like
when you get on that you don't feel
terrified like memorizing your lines or
just just like yeah yeah it's really
wild because you do you have to hit your
mark with the horse that's what I'm
saying yeah no it's it it's like a
choreography insane yeah
um but I it's funny because the uh the
trainer that I work with is just
wonderful Tamara she just so she what
she does is
for for her kids that she's training she
actually puts them on the horse in front
of her and I said honey let's do that
let's just I know I'm I know I'm 30
years old but just let's all ride in
with you and learn how to do this thing
oh my God I love that you're a fitness
saddle with another butt
that's something to be proud of my butt
like I just pictured a saddle like my
Saddles it's doing the job all in its
own just with my butt like I'm like oh
my God that's so amazing for you oh my
God
I love that that's where I went I was
like I was like I'm just picturing my
butt like in a seat where like on a
saddle it's like I'd end up like the
other way like Jennifer Lopez in that
movie like anyway
um
oh Lord there's a lot there
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]